can own a new cycle with one tweet and I
think that speaks to both the power of
his presence and personality but also
his message and his ability to captivate
hi I'm hope Ickx I'm 28 years old and I
am the press secretary for the Donald J
Trump for president campaign and now the
Donald J Trump transition team
I think campaigns and and the politics
of Washington DC are two totally
different things
so I think now being a novice is much
more jarring to me than being a novice
on a campaign because there are so many
people that are new to it you're all
sort of trying to just figure everything
out as it comes to whether you know what
you have experience in it or not
[Music]
I even knew very little about politics
obviously wasn't expecting to take part
in this and certainly not to play the
role that I had I'm just I'm really
proud to been a part of this it's an
incredible thing its historical
obviously and I'm really proud that that
mr. Trump put so much faith in me I'm
really proud that we accomplished this
amazing thing when it sort of seemed
like the odds were against us I think if
I hadn't gotten involved in the campaign
I would hopefully still be working at
the Trump Organization
in a corporate capacity for such a
wonderful family and it builds an
incredible company and it was an honor
to serve them in these different ways
but I'm certainly hope I would still
have that role within the company
you